hello ukraine's president says a
temporary ceasefire announced by moscow
is now on hold because of violations by
russian forces fighting was meant to
stop in mariopol and volnovaca to allow
safe passage of civilians out of harm's
way mario paul has been under siege for
days and has come under constant
shelling
humanitarian corridors must work today
in mariapol and volnovoka to save people
women children the elderly to give food
and medicine to those who remain
we are doing everything on our part to
make the agreement work this is one of
the main tasks for today let's see if we
can go further in the negotiation
process
let's take a closer look at the
humanitarian corridor that had been set
up a route had been established from
mariappol which is home to more than 400
000 to the city of zaparizia it would
have allowed civilians to drive along
the corridor in their own cars or by
taking a municipal bus
charles stratford has more
we are south of the town of the city of
zappos the road behind me we were
expecting to see buses and car loads of
people coming out from the area of
marriott the cars that you can see
behind me now many of them having the
white
signs on the window that we know
we've seen so often saying that there
are children on board
we understand the majority of these
vehicles are not fleeing mariopol but
we've spoken to people further down this
road um who have come out of villages in
between mariopol and here
one man said that
the russians were shelling areas of this
road only 10 kilometers or so back
um
they were shelling the sides of of the
road the nearby fields and
shrapnel had ripped off his tyre and his
wheel was pretty much destroyed
and he had had to drive as fast as he
can to relative safety
to a village before abandoning his car
many of the villagers as you can imagine
are absolutely terrified they say that
the situation has deteriorated
dramatically since we understand that
that ceasefire failed we can't confirm
whether the shelling that we've heard
this morning was either incoming or
outgoing but obviously if there is this
road or areas on this road that is being
shelled that would suggest indeed it is
russian shelling
earlier ukraine's president accused nato
of giving russia the green light to
further bombard and kill ukrainians
because it was refusing to establish a
no-fly zone russia's foreign minister
has hit back in zelinski's speech
accusing him of wanting to provoke
further conflict
if zelensky's so unhappy with nato not
interfering then that means he's hoping
to resolve this conflict by involving
nato it means he's not hearing
statements from european capitals saying
they won't get involved it means he
wants to provoke a conflict between nato
and russia
that's the mood he's in this mood
indicates that he doesn't need
negotiations with us but that may change
because of course he's a moody person
natasha butler is following developments
in the western ukrainian city of levees
the russian foreign minister didn't have
much
good to say of course about the
ukrainian president or ukrainian
authorities ukrainian authorities he
said
were preventing uh that uh evacuation of
citizens from mario paul this town uh on
the sea of azov in the south of ukraine
uh a ceasefire is supposed to be taking
place there between uh russian troops
and uh ukrainian forces but uh that
doesn't seem to be happening uh but
lavrov is saying that that is the fault
of the ukrainian side of ukrainian
troops uh who are not allowing that
humanitarian corridor and ceasefire to
take place he also uh talked about uh
zielinski vladimir silenski the
ukrainian president accusing him of
trying to provoke uh nato possibly
trying to provoke nato into into
becoming part of this conflict uh
zelensky earlier he did call on nato to
try and impose a no-fly zone over the
country he says that would help stop
russian jets and planes uh from
bombarding cities and towns across the
country nato though has made it very
clear that they do not intend to do that
jen stoltenberg the head of nato uh
saying that there won't be
any way in which the alliance is going
to send jets to shoot down or use any
form of artillery to shoot down russian
planes over ukrainian airspace because
that would basically draw the military
alliance into this war something that
western allies say they do not want to
be part of
ukraine's president zolensky is set to
speak virtually to the entire u.s senate
shortly let's find out more and bring in
heidi joe castro joining us from
washington dc so tell us more about this
heidi
well doreen before congress right now is
a pending aid package to ukraine that
totals some 10 billion dollars it's for
military assistance humanitarian as well
as economic and it does have bipartisan
support and it could move as quickly as
being signed into law next week so today
the zoom appearance by president
zielinski before the full senate is the
ukrainian leader's chance to make a
direct appeal about how that money can
be best used to help his country but
what zielinski is expected to ask for of
course is
what he says he most needs right now the
u.s involvement in establishing a no-fly
zone and it is the one thing that the
bidet administration has been consistent
and clear in saying that ukraine cannot
have the reasoning for that again just
as we heard in the case with european
allies is that the u.s does not want to
escalate this into a direct armed
conflict between u.s forces that may
potentially have to shoot down russian
planes to enforce a no-fly zone and that
is a red line
from the white house as far as congress
is concerned there have been one or two
voices the vast minority saying that the
u.s should think about doing a no-fly
zone in ukraine but the vast majority of
congress has been opposed to that idea
as well and i'm sure president zielinski
this morning will be trying to change
those minds yeah it'll be interesting to
see the impact
that seeing zelensky face to face
might have on senators
yeah it will not be lost on anyone here
in washington that these will be people
in their suits and ties waking up on a
peaceful beautiful spring day in
washington speaking with the embattled
ukrainian president the first time that
the full senate will be seeing zilinski
face to face albeit virtually since the
beginning of the war he'll be in his
bunker
in kiev while russian troops threaten to
encircle his city so that contrast
surely will not be lost on anyone
zielinski a week ago made a similar
appearance before european leaders and
he was very effective when he told those
leaders that that may be the last time
they see him alive and of course that
was a huge part in getting that severe
sanctions package passed so we'll have
to see how effective he may be here in
washington there is near universal
praise for his courage with some some
members of the of the us congress even
comparing him to winston churchill so
cementing that moral support i'm sure
that is something that zelinski seeks to
do he could accomplish but as far as
moving the needle to further action
beyond that aid package that is a
challenge that we'll have to see whether
he can deliver on all right thank you
heidi thank you for that reporting from
washington dc